>> Welcome Manuel. It's
great having you here.
I hope you enjoyed yourself.
>> Thank you, Eric.
It has been great.
First of all, it's a wonderful
playground, and secondly,
you have these very
interesting people,
one after the other.
>> It's a kind of place one
can stay for like 25
years and not get tired.
Yes, so it's interesting because
I've followed the work that
you are well known for,
for which you received
the Turing Award a few years back.
I personally didn't know
about your deep interest in
brains and minds before some little
recent discussion we had, so-
>> I think that the rest
of it was side.
I got pushed in the wrong direction.
I'm finally doing what
I really want to do.
>> Tell me a bit more
about the background.
You mentioned this really cool story
during your talk yesterday.
Or I say fun story.
>> How I got into this?
>> Yeah, your father
and his request to you.
>> Yeah. So, the beginning
was when I was a young kid,
I learned English in the Bronx when
I was about to go
into the first grade.
>> What was your first language?
>> My first language was
German for four years.
Then my parents came to this country.
Nobody liked to hear German because
they were at war with Germany.
So they switched to Spanish.
I always spoke a language that nobody
understood until I went
into grade school.
I remember, I knew I
had to learn English,
I was going to go to first grade.
I saw two women in the corner
speaking to each other
and I stood there with
my back to them so they
wouldn't know I'm spying.
I remember listening to them and
telling myself exactly this,
"I will never learn this language,
they speak much too fast for me."
The interesting thing about this is
I'm remembering that in English,
and it couldn't have been English.
>> That's funny, some sort of
internal translation over the years.
>> Since I didn't speak English,
I didn't do that well in school,
and by the time I got to the
second grade, the teacher,
I was pretty dumb and
the teacher said to my mother,
parents-teachers
conference, "You know,
he may be able to get through
high school but he'll
never get to college."
So this bothered me because I-
>> So that was actually
shared with you?
>> That was shared with me.
>> I see.
>> Third or fourth grade.
>> You knew your limitations, yeah.
>> Yeah. It was before
the fourth grade.
So yeah, it was second grade.
So the teacher advised my mother
to start speaking English to me,
and my mother told her,
"I don't speak English."
Teacher responded, "Well, what do
you think you're talking to me?"
So when my mother switched,
I learned English.
I remember that when
I switch to Spanish,
for four-five year to German.
>> Now why Spanish?
>> I was born in Venezuela.
>> Ah, that's right. Okay.
>> Where they all speak Spanish.
So my first language is German,
when they speak Spanish
I didn't understand.
I remember when my mother
switched to Spanish in the Bronx,
that one month later
after she had switched,
she discovered, she realized to
her shock that I had
forgotten my German.
I could see her at the
window saying, "Window.
How do you say window?
Fenster." Because I didn't know that.
So I pride myself in being
able to learn languages
but I'm even better
at forgetting them.
>> That's great. It keeps
your mind flexible.
So knowing that you might finish
high school and then go off
to do something that was
probably non-intellectual
for the rest of your life.
How did you take to this?
The prognosis from the teacher
and being passed up by your parents.
>> Oh yeah. So I really wanted
to be able to think better.
And I was having trouble with memory.
Couldn't remember stuff.
So I asked my father,
"How can I think better?
How can I memorize?"
He just said, "Well, you just do it."
Which didn't help me at all.
Then after I pestered him
enough, he suggested,
"You know, if you understood
how the brain works,
that would help you
to become smarter."
I consider that the most wonderful
advice that one can give a kid.
A kid in the first,
second grade is just right
to get a focus for his life.
That was just wonderful for me.
>> Yes that's interesting
that we never really
think that we don't
have an owner's manual on
this incredible machine,
and we're expected to
just somehow fly by wire,
by learning as we go.
When there's probably a lot we can do
with reflection,
introspection, guidance,
understanding how to learn better,
how to challenge
ourselves intellectually.
Why a math problem that seems
really hard shouldn't be a blocker,
it should be a question
as to why I can't
understand it, and to tackle,
and to think about it.
>> Absolutely. Yeah.
>> Now, do you think that
question from your father
framed the curiosity you
have about minds and brains
or were you already getting
curious about it on your own?
>> Well, that was the beginning.
But certainly, I'm lucky
that we moved a lot.
So, I have my memories placed-
>> Your living milestones.
>> Yeah. So between
the third and fifth grade,
we had moved out of the Bronx,
I was in Westchester
County in New York.
So I can remember I would go to
the library and take
out books on the brain,
and I was a little
embarrassed because other kids
were taking out Black Beauty.
>>You're trying to find
that owners manual sometimes-
>> I'm trying to find
the owners manual. I would
open the book to the back thing so
that librarian could stamp it
so she wouldn't see what
it was I was taking out.
>> So, when you went
to MIT to do double E,
the idea of you actually
finding your way into the lab,
which to me is mind-blowing,
of McCulloch and Pitts,
because I read that paper
years ago I said, "Oh my god,
these people are
the first people to write
down and abstract what a neuron is.
It's a mathematical unit
and then build circuits.
Formal neuron and you actually
work with these people.
>> Wonderful people.
These were wonderful.
Can't tell you, Marvin Minsky
was my thesis adviser,
but Warren McCulloch
was really my mentor.
>> That's fabulous.
>> Walter Pitts, his sidekick
who really taught me a lot.
Walter, for example, told me that,
"Anything you want to know
you can get from books."
Now, it's an overstatement
because there are
things that we want to
know that you cannot get from books,
and that's the sort of thing
we do research for.
But the truth is, there's
a lot you can get from books.
Walter would go to a library
and take out books,
and every so often,
the librarian would tell him,
"You got to bring those books back
so you can get a wheelbarrow."
Literally, a wheelbarrow to be
able to bring the books back.
>> Sounds like the overdue fines
would be quite extensive for him.
You need a wheelbarrow
full of dollars and coins.
Describe, I mean, people listening
to this maybe don't have
the same admiration for
McCulloch and Pitts that I have,
since being quite young and reading
about brains and minds myself
but what they did with
their in paper 1943.
>> Yeah. This wonderful paper that
introduced the formal neuron,
and the formal neuron
with its inputs and they
basically proved that you
have to have inhibition,
not just with excitation alone,
you could not have, they were doing,
the theorem was that you could use
these formal neurons to
construct a Turing machine.
Nowadays, we know you can do that,
but at that time,
this was the paper that showed it.
In the process of showing this,
they saw that you
only can do very much
unless these formal neurons get
both excited and inhibited.
So they told the other
neurophysiologists
there is inhibition in the brain,
and the neurophysiologists
at the time said, "No.
We've never seen them",
and they said, "It's
got to be there".
>> Now we know it's not only there
but it's a major major player.
>> Well, for sure it's
a major player. Yes.
>> Very interesting and so-
>> They founded after that,
he insisted that the lesson-.
>> You say they depended on during
the- under the watch of McCulloch
and Pitts that we had timeframe?
>> In that timeframe.
>> That's fabulous.
>> The first, in the goldfish retina,
they found a neuron which had
very thick fiber coming in
and it was an inhibitor,
whatever that neuron was doing,
when this thing fired,
it stopped that neuron cold.
>> Very interesting. So until you
experience in that lab
got you thinking
more deeply about the
mathematics that might
be important in brains and minds.
So it's interesting to
think how you went from
this interest which clearly
is now that I understand
your background and you've presented
yesterday at your
distinguished lecture,
how that frames
a number of things that
you did including the work on
recursion and so on,
that behind this was interested
in some questions about minds?
>> Yes, I did think that
recursive function theory
and logic were the kinds of
mathematics I needed
in order to build
this manual of how the brain
works in order to understand-
>> I think I can just
describe a little bit about
the work on recursion that you did
maybe in a broad sense of what
the intent and the results there.
>> I'll describe one thing.
>> Yes.
>> That's interesting
which is not mine,
it's this proof that a Turing machine
to simple type of computer can
start out on a blank tape,
can actually print out
its own description on the tape.
It's called the recursion
theorem and it shows you,
exactly the proof
shows you how to build
a Turing machine so that it
prints out its own description,
and this is part of machine
that can then self-reproduce,
you first print out a description,
and then you go to
a constructor which
sees the description
and then builds it.
>> What does that imply
about systems that could
reflect about their own thinking
processes for the same logics?
>> Yeah. So that sound very related,
I mean for one thing it
means that Turing machine can
print out its own description,
and then modify it,
and then follow
these new instructions,
which it tells you
why I got interested in
recursive function theory,
I would not do it that way.
>> I understand. Also speaking
about doing it that way.
Let's talk a bit
about this pursuit of
some formalism that could
describe a model of conscious
experience or consciousness.
Of course when you mentioned
that word you end up
navigating a space where you passed
philosophers and
people are doing with
imprecise terms and not making
good progress this idea.
>> Its crazy actually.
>> It's crazy out there, right.
>> People think I'm actually nuts.
What am I doing,
so I have a friend Aegon Bala,
she was 96 years old,
still quite active and he
absolutely refuses to believe
that a machine could actually
feel the feelings he has when he
fell in love or when he hears music.
>> Doesn't he believe
that that will make
incredible existence proofs
of homosapiens?
>> Yes. So it's interesting.
I have, yeah, how come?
You know how human beings
think they are closest to God,
that they are in the center of
the universe and I've
really always hated that,
I terribly hated that and I was so
happy that there things
like Copernicus saying,
"Well, this earth is not at
the center of
the universe, the sun is".
Then there were many examples like
that where we find that
we're not as so different
from the other animals and there was
a time when life seemed to be
completely different from non-life,
that it was, it seemed impossible-.
>> Imbued with a special spirit.
>> Right. How can you go from
F equals MA, to life spirit?
Impossible, yet it works, right?
Again, it works and I think we're at
that same point now
where people say, "Okay.
So we can get life.",
but feeling emotion
that we kick that,
we'll never get that.
>> Well maybe, before we go
there, let's just do it this.
I think it's important to
make this discrimination
with this distinction.
We'll get more deeply into
system high-level
descriptions because we
don't have a white board hear
yet we have one you can use.
But with slides.
>> Okay. I will be better with it.
>> But we'll talk more about
the particular modelling that
you linguistically will describe
the model you have in mind,
that's exciting you
and Lenore right now,
your wife and your colleague on and
from your should get colleagues
on this front, in this pursuit.
But I wanted to ask the question
is stepping back a bit,
so I want just clear up
some confusion which might even help
with folks understanding of
what it is that you're doing.
There is still this distinction
between coming up with
definition and
computational architecture
and even algorithms
that might run on it,
that you'd call a model
of consciousness,
a machine-based model of
consciousness that may
even read on what
human brains are doing.
Distinguishing that
from the coming up with
some deeper understanding
or tuition about the nature
of subjective experiences in qualia.
I think last night when
were chatting you,
you did make that distinction.
So look, I'm not going to capture
those questions yet and which
is to say more about that part,
because I wanted to first distinguish
those two things and then move
ahead on the architecture?
>> Okay. Sure. So I'm a
theoretical computer scientists.
So let me make the point
about how this theoretical
computer science works.
It works by creating models and
making definitions and whether
these models are correct
or not depends on
the results you get and
whether they agree.
So for example, this is the
definition of zero-knowledge proof,
where you can convince somebody
that a theorem is true
in such a way that they can't turn
around and convince anybody else,
it's a beautiful definition of
zero knowledge due to, okay so-.
>> Anyway. So there's
this beautiful definition and
it's sound that even the term
zero now suggests that,
if I give you a zero-knowledge
proofs that you're getting
no information other than
the truth of the theorem.
This is the way it's described,
you get no information
but it's not true.
For example, when I,
if I give you
a zero-knowledge proof you
learn something about
the actual length of the proof.
You also learn that I know the proof
because you can't give a zero-knowledge
proof without knowing that,
you'll know that there's a lot
of additional information,
the point is that
a good definition can
actually give you an understanding
of what's going on.
So the way I'm doing it here,
and this is the way theoretical
computer scientists work,
as I make a model and
I create make or we,
Lenore and I will make
this model and then
we define that this is
what consciousness is,
this is what a chunk is,
this is what short-term memory is
and people may or may not agree.
>> But there are allusions
between those structures and
those portions of
the definition and then how
the mechanism works
and what you believe
personally is ethical and not
in human minds at some level.
>> Absolutely. I mean, when I define
we are consciously aware of
what's in working memory,
we're not aware of anything
else that's going on,
but in the model, I can
define that precisely.
This is what we're conscious of,
whether this actually corresponds to
what's going on in the brain
and most people will say,
"That's not the way it works".
>> Okay. Again, just back to
my other earlier comments
slash question and distinction.
You could carry assume
deeply and it might even
be a great explanation
for certain aspects of
what's going on in human minds or
even a nice blueprint for what
evolution discovered when it came up
with very great minds
and Homosapiens,
but ones that are now
interacting across this table.
But there's still a distinction
there between going
from that to some
workable, understandable,
explanation of why that
would cause the feeling,
the feelings is going to
quote the extra experiences,
that pains and pleasures
themselves being here.
I wanted to just take off the table
now because we're not
going to get to that
probably today but maybe you,
we will get to that as
community for decades or
forever that particular distinction.
>> Well, I certainly hope
we will get to it within
my lifetime which is right now
no more than 10 more years.
>> Come on, you're going
to go further than that.
>> Whatever, but the point is I do
think we can get to what
that feeling is about.
>> But right now, that's
not part of your,
in any way part of the model
itself in terms of
the even the current local goals
of laying out the model and being
precise about what
short term memory is?
For example, versus long-term.
>> Well, laying out
the model allows me to
define vast of divine things
like consciousness of the terms,
and we tried to use this now to
actually find out what it is
that generates the feelings.
There are many possible feelings.
My particular interest is
the feeling of pain
that we sometimes feel.
>> But again, before
we get into that,
I want to dive into a deep dive
with you right now on
these topics and how it works.
But even just a pre-fetch a bit here.
Even the pain thing that we
talked about, that
you'll be talking about,
is not necessarily
the subjective quality
that we have as humans of
pain, that's a different.
It might be related, but
we're not sure why that's
happening in terms of
how that's generated
or why this part of our universe
that the mechanism seems
to be able to do that.
>> I think that once we've
proven the theorems about
how this works anything,
and can suggest experiments that
maybe our model predictions.
It's like McCulloch predicting
that there must be
inhibition in the brain.
I want to make some predictions
which come out of the model,
which suggests that these notions
of the feelings of pain are correct.
>> So this idea of there being
a big massive sea of
impressive and broad,
so conscious reasoning processes
that we don't have direct access to,
and then some notion of
a smaller conscious process that
somehow the subconscious
pops ideas and
solutions up into to some sort of
a thresholding process has been
around broadly for awhile,
and it was one that I
reflected about suddenly.
I've seen in writings for years,
and I know they've been
influential in your own thinking,
who are some of the people
that have worked on
this outside of might say
theoretical computer science?
>> Yeah. So, the main first person
I found out about was Bernie Bohrs,
but the stand to him
he has a wonderful.
>> Describe [inaudible] connected to
describe Bohr's model a detainees,
it's interesting to see,
its global theatre for example.
>> Yeah. So Bohr's model
this is global theater that,
I think of theatre in which
there's an actor on the stage.
Usually, just one
actor, maybe a couple.
Mainly, one actor and
there's audience,
processors, the audience of
people who have specialties.
Each person in that audience has
their own special interests.
One of them really loves chess,
and knows about chess
and if anybody on
the stage asks a question about
like what move to make next,
and he said that this chess
program would look at it.
>> It's really [inaudible]
other psychologists like
John Anderson for example had the act
are kind of weird.
>> Right.
>> Yeah. So, they have
their own models and again,
I think that difference is,
so John Anderson says
the brain is very complicated,
the model cannot be simple,
and we say Illinois and I say "The
mathematics can only deal with very
simple ideas",
very simple constructs.
We need a very simple model.
So, in this way is
different from the others.
I want the simplest model like start
to make definitions and
prove theorems about.
>> So let's dive into it now.
So, we stick the global
generics of a globe,
this global theater model
and let's now
carry forward into Computer Science.
>> Sure. Maybe you
want an application.
For example, what would this,
I have an iPhone here,
and if I want to look up this person
that I met this morning here.
Her name is AJ.
>> AJ Kumar.
>> AJ Kumar, right.
If I want to look her up a month
from now, how will I find her?
Will I find her by googling for AJ.
Probably, you won't find it
because it's not under AJ.
Her name is Bob ECE.
So, do I look in the calendar?
Do I look in to my phonebook?
Where will I find her?
So, in this model consciousness,
the way this would work as you ask
the question and all of
these apps that you have here,
the calendar, the Google or
the being that all of
these different apps.
Hear the question and try to
answer it. Wouldn't that be nice?
You don't know where
the information is,
but you ask the question
and they all work on it,
and the one that has
the answer pops it up to you,
and I love that idea.
I hate having to search around
through all of these absolute.
They could be doing this one.
>> Said, yeah there's there's
some notion in your model of,
call it the stage, the executive,
that short term memory
as you referred to it,
and somehow it can make
requests down or broadcast.
>> It can broadcast, right?
It can make a request. They won't
always be answered the way you want.
I have this pain,
and could you please
turn that pain off.
For some reason the processor
has refused to do that.
What's her name?
The processor will respond.
>> So, just go to the basic.
If you just drop the architectures
of basic ideas of how this all works.
>> You have the stage on top.
You have all of these individual
processors at the bottom,
and whatever is on the stage is
broadcast bound to the processors,
so that they all are paying
attention to what's on the stage.
The stage presumably has
very little information.
>> How do they get back
to that information?
>> Then those processors have to
send their information backup.
But of course, the stage
is very small.
Only one or two of
those processors can get up there,
and so some sort of
they have to decide
amongst themselves which is
the most important
information to get up there.
So, we thought about
this question of how to do this,
what communication can they do to
decide and we realized it
can't be very complicated,
if the information has to
go up there very fast.
So, we decided that really it's
going to be no more than
comparing two numbers.
There's one processor has
some information which has
certain weight plus three,
and another processor has information
that values as plus five.
So, one with plus five goes
up one level rather
than the plus three.
So, it's just a simple
comparison of numbers,
and then there's the
question of course of,
well where do these numbers
come from in the first place?
Basically, you can say that
like for example is pain,
the pain processor for
the pain in my shoulder,
the pain processor can see
how many nerve fibers are firing,
nose receptor firings,
how fast they're firing
and it chooses a weight
based on that information.
This can be true for
all of the processors.
There are ways for them to measure
and some measurements
are too optimistic,
pushing too hard to get up there,
some measurements
are too pessimistic,
and the nice thing is we
discovered that our son
offer them had exactly
this kind of a model,
and we had written a paper
called the sleeping experts.
All these processors down below.
>> What a great way
to solve problems!
Had a kid to do it for you?
>> Yes, and we fortunately have that.
So, his algorithm basically is
telling you how you compare these,
how you are able to reduce
or raise the weights
of these processors,
so that they are essentially.
Their weights are optimally chosen.
>> There's several areas of science
where this kind of thing is
done in the area of search retrieval,
but you have a big graph with
weights and the idea of figuring out,
sort of what's
a good ranking function that
we bring back the right
results given a query.
Not that far off from
some of these concepts of
>> I don't think this
is far off at all.
The only thing that far
off is that I'm going
to try very hard to be able
to get to what's causing
the agony in pain,
what's causing
the suffering and pain.
But I want to be able to,
or the pleasure, the joy.
I want to get at the quality.
I want to get at the hard problem.
>> I am concerned that we'll
be making that leap be tough,
even from a great and intuitively
pleasing architectural solution,
passes me, specifying some sense
that it might be difficult.
>> I hear you.
>> So I would love to define
that link, to do that link with you.
>> So, Lenore looks
especially a joy which
had a very hard problem.
I look at pain which I think easier.
>> This is great captionary match.
>> It's really wonderful, yes.
So, I look at pain
and there are many explanations
for why we have this feeling of pain,
but one of them is that when
you have really serious pain,
you cannot think about anything else.
Whatever it is you want to
think about, you cannot.
If it's really extreme pain,
you are killed as far as-
>> Problem-solving,
general problem-solving.
>> -general problem-solving.
One of the things that makes
me think maybe that I'm on
the right track is
the fact that this is
the most anti-Darwinian notion
you can imagine.
I mean, here I am,
something has fallen on my foot,
I'm under extreme pain,
I really need to get rid of it,
and I can't even
think of how to do it
because I'm in so much pain.
>> We discussed yesterday,
I don't want to
use interpretation of that,
even though it's sad,
which is that the solution for
Darwinianism was to get rid of
that human being out of
the tribe immediately happens,
lay on the ground that
if minus one away.
>> Yes, you did.
>> So, anyway so some
explanation for this,
but go ahead though, yes so.
>> So, here's a point.
If we can understand
that there's something
we might be able to do,
right now and doctors want to
know how much pain you're in,
they have this set of 10 faces
from the happy face to
the one that's crying,
and they say, "Where's your pain?"
This is the best that
they can do right now.
I mean they can try to use
fMRI and other methods,
but this is actually
the way they do it,
the best they have.
The doctors have a problem,
somebody comes in with
that shoulder pain,
and they don't know, is
this person really in pain,
and really should get those pills?
Or is it that he wants to get
pills to sell on the street?
I think we might be
able to come up with,
if we understand this well enough,
we might be able to come up with
a solution for the physician.
How to tell whether that person
is how much pain
that person really feels.
Part of that solution,
we feel will come from the fact
that if it's very serious pain,
you can't think that clearly.
Though, less pain, the more
clearly you can think,
and we might be able to
use that to create a test.
>> Tapping to related topic.
What do you think about people that
say there's really
no such thing as consciousness,
it's just the way machines
that have these abilities
happened to feel, to perceive.
You can't have
these abilities without
it feeling like this to
be one of these machines?
>> Yeah.
>> It's just a definitional thing
and when we make a big deal
out of something that's
just the magic of being
a powerful intellect.
>> Yeah, so the wonderful thing about
this mathematical model is
I can define consciousness.
This is what's conscious
and nothing else is,
and I want to prove
theorems about that.
>> It's great.
>> Maybe it's that what you
consider the conscious.
That's okay, this is my definition,
and this is what the
theorems are about.
>> So many people that watch
this fireside chat are younger folks
who are thinking about
their career or even mid-career
folks who are thinking about
maybe change of career
for topics they look at with
what they're thinking about.
I'm just impressed
that you stuck with
your early curiosities
your whole life
even when it wasn't clear that
that's what you're working on,
winning the Turing Award for,
you stuck with this passion and
interest about brains and minds.
>> Not that I had much choice.
I mean, that was what
I'm passionate about.
I don't feel like
there was much choice,
I had to work on it.
I still work on other things.
>> But some people
don't believe they have
the flexibility or the ability to
stick with their main
curiosity and interest.
So I know you stopped with this
and you have made
choices and passion.
>> I left it and I came back.
>> Why did you leave and come back?
>> Well, in part because
we really couldn't
start to look at how the brain
works until fMRI came on the scene.
So even when I met McCulloch
and Pitts that was 1963,
I wasn't allowed to think
about consciousness.
We did could had no way
to get into the brain,
find out how it's working.
>> Many people would save it today,
and fMRI in that simply getting
us that much further with-
>> Right.
>> -model of consciousness.
>> Their models are so pretty.
>> Yeah.
>> I'm not getting to
consciousness, that's right.
>> But again, it sent us
support for you is since
for getting to be emeritus,
it's like, "Okay, I want to really
know the study what I want to study."
>> It does help. First of
all, getting tenure help.
I can do something that's
a little bit nuts.
I'm now 80 years old,
that helps a lot.
>> Just go for it.
>> You might as well go
for it, there's nothing.
They can't do me any damage,
I mean, I might as
well find that well.
>> So there's a little bit of
caution earlier in
life in your career?
>> Well, they has to be. My father
told me if you understood the brain,
he pushed for it.
Yet, when I told him and this was in
fifth grade that I
decided I was going
to become an anthropologist,
connections to the brain.
My father stood up at the table.
I remember and said,
"You will not be
an anthropologist,
anthropologists are professors.
Professors can't make a living,
you will not be an anthropologist."
>> Wow, well it's just like.
Let me end by asking
you this question.
Let's say even in our lifetimes
we get to the bottom of things,
and we can verifiably build
a conscious computer that
has some of the many of
the attributes of conscious,
we understand to be part of
being a vertebrate creature,
a Homo sapien,
what would that mean to
our self-conception, to the world,
to our sense for what computer
science is, for what people are?
>> People are, so this problem
came up at one time with chess.
Computers can play chess.
What would it mean I was asked
if computers could play chess?
What would that mean to
our conception of ourselves?
People are playing chess
all the time even though
they're easily beatable
by the machines.
Yeah, that has to change.
>> Now, we have
some chess players that
play with machines
against each other.
>> All right, yeah new games.
>> As complementary
computing systems.
>> Right.
>> Yeah.
>> Look, football is a game
that we like to play,
you can build a robot that
would beat any football player.
>> But, there's something
about conscious experience.
I think that's it's at the root of
this deep curiosity and
sense of the magic of
being the points up or sideways or
down towards spirits and
powers beyond science.
I guess, my sense is that's what's
going on over the centuries.
It's based in the magic of what
it is to feel like a human.
>> Yeah, so that is what
people don't believe
that really I can get
to the basis to solve
the hard problem because
that's beyond science.
My response is well, so far,
there were all sort of things
that were beyond science that
turned out to be
scientifically solvable.
>> In some ways you're saying there
may have been an initial
shock or reaction,
but after a few weeks,
back to normal again, and
yes we understand that now.
>> I think despite
the fact that almost
everybody thinks I'm crazy and
that this cannot possibly be,
I do think that we
will get the solution,
and this will be very
positive for us.
>> You know something? I agree
with you. Thanks for being here.
>> Thank you.
>> Appreciate it.